happy Tuesday reject nation greg ever
hear the english version which is
exactly how i like to watch all animes I
hate Japanese English like reading and I
don't like watching it in the format
it's meant to be watched in I'm probably
gonna watch in the Japanese language but
anyway yeah they have this English
trailer out here I hear to offer some
new stuff no details yet in my mind
shout out today cuz it's Tuesdays
Tuesday and it was her birthday
Erika Tuesday patron the day shout-out
My Dear John will handle that one cuz
apparently I make the same joke every
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
our master has ordered us to kill him on
sight
only do with us sweets will try to take
over this country rewrite history
oh the Batmobile the bad wind the
bat-cycle they've all been destroyed at
the hands of the Joker and I have my
mind my spirit and all of you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
whoa that's pg-13 damn he's always
already anime films now from dude that
does look epic honestly and for an
english dubbed anime film i think it's
fine for what we got I still would
prefer to watch the Japanese version but
we're going to feudal Japan and it's a
time to be English it's a time travel
movie of Batman who's American yeah I
mean it doesn't bother me that much I
can see having Batman speak English and
some of them you know Batman Gotham
characters speak English but I don't
feel like it's a movie that needs to be
in English you get a better sense of
what the plot is here yeah that man's
time travel back to Japan they're trying
to rewrite history the bat villains and
mainly led by the Joker and then you got
the bat family working with him well
there that I don't know like the dojo
meditating or whatever you see the bat
family there you get Batman you get Red
Robin you get the Red Hood you get
Nightwing yeah regular Robin and I think
in the other trailer you do see that he
does have his own kind of Batmobile but
he's talking here about he doesn't have
his equipment he doesn't have his
gadgets but he's still got his mind and
his skills and ability so this really is
going into Batman being the samurai the
Dark Knight the warrior hey that was
actually what hooked me that the very
most about this trailer especially
jumping off from the first one is that
it is gonna be his intellect and his
skills more than anything else and I
love that about Batman and I also love
that in the context of this like
historical fiction take yeah you know
where he's forced to rely on just what
special about him no it looks freakin
awesome this looks sexy as hell I like
the you know getting to know a little
bit more about the story I really like
this and I just like this weird little
trend we're visiting of period Batman's
stories because there was Gotham by
Gaslight now there's this I hope they do
some live action films like this in the
future I'm talking a little bit about
that in a that I already shot with Joey
Ross some cinematics about how we want
like a live-action period piece
comic-book adaptations the looks and
designs of everyone
here looks awesome with the Harley Quinn
and Catwoman
Alfred even Albert actually looks the
most similar this looks like regular
Alfred just has a little bit of a
Japanese aesthetic to him but the anime
look on everyone most cool you got like
sumo Bane in here at one point which is
so awesome I really feel like what the
designs of this were when they took the
approach was if these characters were in
an anime what would they be what would
they look like
let's do that time period yeah which is
such a fun thing to do it yeah I like
cruising scrubbing the timeline of this
video even you can see all these little
details and design choices yeah so cool
right I haven't really been into anime
in my life but in the past month and a
half I've been getting into anime you
know started doing reactions for attack
on Titan or patreon been watching Cowboy
Bebop with my girlfriend I'm really
excited for Batman ninja now the only
thing I've ly the only thing I'm kind of
iffy about you know going into this or
anticipating this movie is the the
literal animation style cuz I'm kind of
torn on that looking at this there's
something about when they do the
hand-drawn anime but you can tell that
it's computer manipulated yet and like
there are certain moments where I feel
like that could come together really
well because like some of those
backgrounds look like a real watercolor
and then you have like different
animation styles blended but there are
also other moments especially like
action moments in this roguelike I can
tell that this is a computer and not
entirely hand-drawn so that's well make
your own yeah yeah I can't do that I
think in this one shot here it might
been a little bit of a spoiler when
they're all running away from the big
explosion looks like Gorilla Grodd is
helping carry some of them and gorilla
grodd is pretty much a bad guy and a lot
of these stories sometimes good or yeah
maybe they're carrying him because their
arms his arms around them so maybe they
team up with him or they save him you
even because that's Batman's motto
you know don't kill I hope he kills on
this one there was a samurai
[Laughter]
remember the Japanese equivalent of
Martha well yeah this looks great but
before we wrap this video up Erica
Tuesday Erica - happy birthday to you
glad you finally turned nineteen you
look great for your age and you do
animations John flash that flash that
pain where'd you get that picture
oh go get it go get it jump cut to it
yeah some original art original art by
my homegirl I love this piece there's
some original arbitrary Tuesday dreams
but I think it's wonderful find a place
to hang it up so yeah she did some sexy
drawings and she does some pretty sick
animes as well John she's a close friend
of yours so won't you give her a good
happy birthday wish sure Eric uh happy
birthday to you I would like to thank
you for being you for bringing color and
and you know warmth into my life for
being so welcoming alive
stop now I'm trying to give a heartfelt
I appreciate you you're the best don't
stop and hang in there give your arms a
rest I'm just gonna keep going and see
tell me to stop just you know give your
arms a rest you know from human printer
oh that's why you're saying to give your
arms right oh yeah she draws all day
yeah happy birthday I got a beautiful
gal glad to see you turn nineteen
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up people and
go check out our patreon full-length TV
show music video reactions over there
weekly Q&A s and a much more extra
goodies that we offer